it wasn't a blanket statement towards
women or to feel like
i don't respect the work or think that
they don't work hard i know that they do
that was taken out of context but
i'm i'm really sorry if it was received
that way
kim kardashian responds to the wave of
backlash she received after dishing out
this business advice to women i have the
best advice for women in business get
your ass up and work
let's rewind earlier this month the 41
year old kkw beauty founder joined her
sisters courtney and chloe along with
their mom kris jenner for a candid chat
with variety and when the mag asked kim
about the secret to her success she
didn't hold back get your ass up and
work
it seems like nobody wants to work these
days
but it didn't stop there you have to
surround yourself with people
that want to work
have a good work environment where
everyone loves what they do because you
have one life no toxic work environments
and show up and do the work well some
people weren't feeling kim's words of
wisdom we have different views sometimes
stars like megan mccain and jamila jamil
weighed in on twitter pointing out that
the skim's founder grew up in beverly
hills with a lot of privilege jamila
writing quote nobody needs to hear your
thoughts on success work ethic i think
people think i hate the kardashians i
don't hate them the ladies of the view
weighed in too i just think that people
that are born on third base shouldn't be
talking about how easy it is to hit a
home run regina hall and wanda sykes
even quoted kim on sunday night while
hosting the 2022 academy awards
and this is from uh
a quote from kim kardashian
work harder that's right
well on monday kim addressed the critics
saying that the now infamous sound bite
was taken out of context
it became a sound bite really with no
context and the question right before
was after 20 years of being in the
business you're famous for being famous
and i
my whole tone and attitude changed with
the previous question that went into
that question about
what advice would you give to women but
following kim's gma appearance variety's
chief correspondent elizabeth wagmeister
who did the interview with the
kardashians shot down kim's claims
tweeting that the question about being
famous for being famous actually came
after she was asked to give her best
business advice
having a social media presence and being
on a reality show does not mean
overnight success
and you have to really work hard it
wasn't a blanket statement towards women
or to feel like
i don't respect the work or think that
they don't work hard i know that they do
that was taken out of context but i'm
i'm really sorry if it was received that
way
well some people may not be here for
kim's latest business advice success is
never easy so you just if you put in the
work you will see results it's that
simple
but back in 2018 she told et you've just
gotta go for it i think my smartest
business decision has been
going for it
and not being like having no fear and
just
even if they failed and even if it
hasn't turned out the way that i wanted
to i've learned so much from it so my
advice would be
go for it
[Music]